y
[Música]
en ciudad la represión mortal continúa
contra los manifestantes que se oponen
al golpe de estado que encabezó el jefe
del ejército el general abdelfatah
alborán el 25 de octubre que derrocó a
las autoridades de transición que habían
tomado el relevo del dictador omar al
bashir desde entonces los manifestantes
han estado saliendo a las calles para
exigir el regreso del gobierno civil en
tres meses al menos 79 manifestantes han
sido asesinados según el comité central
de médicos sudaneses nuestro observador
ahmet participa regularmente en estas
manifestaciones
decidimos ocultar su identidad para
preservar su seguridad la represión
adopta diversas formas hay disparos
directamente contra los manifestantes la
mayoría de los mártires fueron golpeados
en la cabeza el pecho y otras zonas
sensibles
el más grave y es la primera vez que lo
vemos es el uso de la ametralladora
pesada las fuerzas de seguridad lo
negaron pero los vídeos publicados en
las redes sociales mostraban los sujetos
con uniformes militares disparando esta
arma
y
la represión adopta diversas formas
también está el lanzamiento de gases
lacrimógenos que se realiza de forma
horizontal esto ha causado muchas
lesiones e incluso muertes ellas en la
cabeza personas que pierden un ojo la
granada de gas lacrimógeno se utiliza
normalmente para dispersar el gas y no
debe dirigirse directamente a las
personas
otra forma de reprimir a los
manifestantes es culturicen sus
vehículos para aplastarlos hubo varias
escenas horribles de vehículos de las
fuerzas de seguridad embistiendo a los
manifestantes
varios manifestantes resultaron heridos
durante estas manifestaciones también se
vio a sujetos vestidos con ropa oficial
que saqueado
roban a ciudadanos que aman y no tienen
nada que ver con las manifestaciones se
han documentado varios casos en las
redes sociales
y en las últimas manifestaciones se ha
visto a personas vestidas de civil que
parecen pertenecer al aparato de
seguridad cuando las primeras líneas de
las manifestaciones
pero a pesar de todos los medios de
represión y utilizados la gente ha
seguido saliendo en masa a la calle en
tres meses para desafiar el golpe
es el agua que tomamos aquí en lituania
esta es sufrimos mucho aquí
estas imágenes fueron tomadas en el
centro de detención de medina inca y en
lituania cientos de inmigrantes en su
mayoría iraquíes llevan meses bloqueados
allí esta es una consecuencia de la
política de belarús de atraer migrantes
a su territorio con la promesa de entrar
en la unión europea en total en 2021 más
de 400 migrantes entraron irregularmente
a lituania una situación sin precedentes
para este pequeño país de la unión
europea
lituania los ubicó en centros de
detención donde viven en un callejón sin
salida cheché originario del áfrica
francófona nos habló de sus condiciones
de detención a juanan y mató por miedo a
las represalias
en el centro tenemos problemas de
higiene por ejemplo el agua que bebemos
a veces es oscura en tres meses hemos
recibido jabones y un gel de ducha desde
que nos bañamos aquí tenemos problemas
de piel picazón
cuando hay una emergencia y llamamos a
la policía no llegan a tiempo las
comidas que nos dan aquí son
insuficientes y todos hemos perdido peso
y nos falta energía el fósforo y el frío
nos afecta demasiado
la calefacción a veces se descompone
tenemos insomnio y problemas mentales
porque hemos estado encerrados durante
mucho tiempo
tenemos problemas con los guardias
fronterizos y zona crisis
son agresivos nos recuerdan todo el
tiempo que no somos bienvenidos en su
país hemos solicitado asilo
pero el resultado es negativo se violan
nuestros derechos porque se nos priva la
libertad y se nos insulta se nos
alimenta mal no tenemos asistencia
jurídica no tenemos esperanza
miren se están llevando a la gente por
la fuerza a ver al consumo miren
a finales de enero las tensiones
volvieron a aumentar ya que las
autoridades lituanas intentaron obligar
a los migrantes congoleños a reunirse
con el cónsul de su país como nos
explicó una ciudadana congoleña
[Aplausos]
vinieron a llevarnos a ver a nuestro
cónsul y nos negamos porque es de estas
autoridades de las que huimos en nuestro
país y como nos negamos empezaron a
amenazarnos a golpearlos para que
fuéramos a ver al cónsul por la fuerza
el parlamento lituano recientemente
autorizó la ampliación de las
detenciones hasta un año
hasta ahora sólo ha sido aceptado el 2%
del total de las solicitudes de asilo
los migrantes temen sobre todo que
lituania los obligue a volver a casa a
cambio de ayuda económica
es todo por esta semana en los
observadores de france 24 si usted
quiere compartir con nosotros sus
historias fotografías y vídeos puede
entrar en contacto con la producción del
programa los datos aparecen en sus
pantallas nos vemos la próxima semana
hasta entonces